Emma Stone is so hot crazy stupid love
star Steve Carell Ryan Gosling Julianne
Moore Emma Stone Marisa Tomei and Kevin
Bacon cast man that's a good cast and
it's a romantic comedy but I don't
really want to describe it as your
standard romantic comedy because it's
actually a very adult romantic comedy I
don't mean in regards to content I mean
just the fact that it's a lot more
mature than the average romantic comedy
it weaves the stories of a whole bunch
of different people all together and it
tells them in such an entertaining way I
really dug this movie
Steve curls character is starting to go
through a divorce of Julianne Moore's
character Ryan Gosling plays this swing
and hip guy who's he's really hilarious
actually in this movie I was very
surprised who's trying to help Steve
Carell be more of a ladies man Emma
Stone and Ryan Gosling are interested in
each other all these characters all
makes it interact with each other at
various points and when a movie does
that right when movie is able to tell
the stories of a whole bunch of
different people and be able to make it
flow and not seem like it's you know
badly paced or out of place all these
different stories are going on that's
really great in this movie hands it's oh
well this is by far my favorite romantic
comedy of the year is actually very
hilarious in fact there's one scene this
movie I won't spoil it but it is
outrageous
I mean I was just dying just everyone
gets great performances and everyone
gets their own moment to shine in the
movie but I personally think that Ryan
Gosling really steals the show here he
hasn't really done much comedy if that
much at all but now when I think and I
look back in a lot of his roles he
always sort of has like this wit and
charm to him he is actually very funny
in this movie and I think he's my
favorite part of this film he was great
Steve Carell was great too I always
really liked him he's
like a master of somehow being able to
combine straight man with the goofy guy
and make it into one character he does
that so well because he's serious while
at the same time being absolutely insane
Julianne Moore turns in a really good
performance that she's actually kind of
funny in the movie - Emma Stone is very
funny in particular in one scene and my
word I just I really like her
why can't I know her in real life this
is a really fun enjoyable movie that is
just a good time of the movies all
around there's actually a lot of
surprises in this movie there's a lot of
twists in this movie and all of them are
add to the hilarity of what's going on
there's really good character
development - because the each character
starts on a certain place in the movie
and by the end of the film they're all
in different places and it's written so
sharply the way all these characters
progress and change throughout the movie
is completely believable I think it's
great they have a romantic comedy like
this that doesn't follow those same
standard cliched patterns of every other
romantic comedy I've really enjoyed it
also there was one scene in the movie
where something happened I was like oh
man that is a big cliche seriously and
then the character goes such a cliche
and I was like that's fantastic they
recognize it and they're acknowledging
it that makes me happy have no glaring
problems with it purely as an
entertainment factor it is not a perfect
film I had a lot of fun with the film
I'm going to give it three and a half
out of four stars it is by far cut above
the average romantic comedy I definitely
suggest checking it out especially if
you like any of those stars it gives
them all moment to shine tomorrow I've
seen Cowboys and Aliens so look forward
to that so if you like to my review
subscribe to my channel and get stuck in
my nice